hello i'm richard gisbert and you're at
the listening post where we don't cover
the news we cover the way the news is
covered
you will have noticed in the dispatches
coming out of ukraine that more and more
media outlets now refer to the country's
capital as kiev not kiev they're opting
for the ukrainian pronunciation over the
russian one it is a slight but
significant change in terminology an
indication of which way the winds are
blowing in this information war
regardless of the advances that russian
forces have been making on the ground
in their president vladimir zelensky
ukrainians have an effective messenger
he's a former comedian turned political
actor who has been rallying support both
at home and abroad
russian media outlets meanwhile are not
even calling this a war they have to
stick to the official lie that it's a
special military operation failure to do
so has its consequences
between the misinformation coming out of
moscow the nato expansion angle that
gets underplayed in the western news
media and the larger battle for hearts
and minds we have a lot to get to our
starting point this week is kiev
in a 21st century information war waged
on multiple digital fronts the russian
attack on the tv tower in kiev felt like
a throwback to an earlier simpler time
when television was king and taking over
the airwaves meant that an invading
force or rebel army could control the
narrative
tv no longer matters the way it once did
but it clearly matters to vladimir putin
the attacking of the cave tv towers of
course deliberate strategy
this is where the actual war and media
were uh converging because putin did his
best to have russian society brainwashed
by propaganda so he assumes that
everyone else is like that too which is
uh wrong on many different levels
because it's really not like ukrainians
are only fighting back because their
television tells them
special
to hear the russian media describe it
there is no war in ukraine just a
special military operation ordered by
the kremlin
when the independent outlet tv dodged
called it an invasion instead and the
radio station echo muskfi did the same
the prosecutor general's office ordered
them to be taken off the air
there are tip for tat measures taken
over the information side of this war by
political players and big tech companies
the european union has banned russian
state-owned channels rt and sputnik
leaving it to its member states and
their regulators to enforce the new
policy
youtube tick-tock and meta which
controls facebook and instagram have all
blocked rt and sputnik news content
google has removed the channels from its
news search tool and dropped their
mobile apps from its play store
russia's media regulator subsequently
throttled twitter slowing its loading
speed down to a crawl for what it called
twitter's failure to take down fake news
posts on ukraine
taking
russian media off the air on on the west
is a bit of an overreaction who is this
supposed to protect i don't think
anybody
in the west is really taking rt or or
these other russian state media
affiliates very seriously to the extent
that they spread propaganda and giving
russia and russian state media the
option of seeming like they are the
victims of some over aggressive western
restrictions on speech and on media
muddies the water on who is suppressing
speech media control is very essential
for putin right now uh
not just russia any country that is in
the middle of a war effort particularly
one as contentious as the one that he's
launched now but there are better ways
to deal with russian misinformation
disinformation than just outright
censorship i'm worried about the
president that sets for one and if the
west is condemning the russian
government for cracking down on speech
and free media over in russia
it's not a great look for the west to be
engaging in activities that appear
uh to be the same for every russia today
that is cancelled in europe for every
youtube
or russian blog that is cancelled you
see uh repercussions for the russian
audience
that is going to be much more severe
it is most likely that bbc and other
major
foreign networks
would be cancelled in russia there's a
likelihood that youtube would be shut
down in russia as well we are already
looking at the limiting of capacity of
facebook
[Music]
news outlets like to tell stories of
heroes and in vladimir zelinski the
western media have their audiences
believing they have found one
the ukrainian president has provided
them with plenty of telegenic material
inspiring ukrainians through his defiant
messages aimed at the kremlin videos
that have gone viral
zelensky's unusual path to power he's a
comedian who once played the president
on ukrainian television usually gets a
mention
what goes under-reported is that
zielenski's politics can be problematic
there's also the small matter of the
azov brigade
an openly fascist military unit that
zelensky's government tolerates within
its army's ranks as long as those
neo-nazi soldiers are fighting russians
in any
wartime scenario there's always a push
to simplify narratives
to
flatten nuance and to turn everything
into a kind of black and white narrative
zielinski does not have fantastic
democratic credentials the ukrainian
security service has investigated one of
his chief rifles the mayor of kiev
vitali kalichka solensk has had a
different political rival put under
house arrest he's closed down
pro-russian independent media outlets
but it complicates the the picture to
cast this as purely a democracy
defending itself against an
authoritarian country which is
somewhat true it's a lot more
complicated than that in reality none of
the lansky's closest aids have any
far-right links at all sure there is a
certain element and yeah clips have
emerged on social media with these
far-right battalions providing military
training to civilians and of course
they've been played on repeat on russian
state media because that's their
tangible proof of far rights presence in
ukraine but they're not in power or we
don't have any political presentation on
the national level
another angle a vital contextual one
underplayed in american and western news
coverage of the ukraine story is the
expansion of nato
premeditated unjustified the u.s state
department briefings fronted by ned
price often include intelligence
assessments from agencies like the cia
the cia's director is william burns he's
done two stints at the embassy in moscow
speaks fluent russian and happens to be
completely out of step with the biden
administration on how this crisis came
to be
in 2019 burns wrote a memoir in which he
called nato's expansion into ex-warsaw
pact countries needlessly provocative
warned that ukraine was the brightest of
all red lines for the russian elite and
not just hardliners he said that even
putin's sharpest liberal critics saw
nato expansion as a direct challenge to
russian interests
you won't see william burns getting any
face time on the american airwaves these
days that would just complicate matters
in a media space where the blame is
vladimir putin's and his alone
the reason we're not hearing about
william burns's warning uh now in the
media is because it really undermines a
lot of the talking points from western
governments that create this flattened
picture of the reality of what we're
seeing and that western actions had
nothing to do with it
because if burns and others who are
willing about this were correct then
that means that there should have been a
different set of policies that were
pursued following the cold war
you acknowledge that u.s or western
actions have
contributed to
russia feeling under an existential
threat people are just saying that this
is tantamount to saying that russia is
justified that you're buying into
russian propaganda in fact no it's
simply modern history this context is
very important and we can't have a full
picture of what's going on over there if
we don't have it nato was always part
part of the story but it was never that
part of the story that could explain or
justify what russia is doing in ukraine
ukraine was not on the verge of
entering nato nato was not providing
ukraine with something that could have
endangered russia in the any foreseeable
future and what is happening to ukraine
is not because of nato it is because of
ukraine not being what russia wants it
to be or specifically what vladimir
putin wants it to be
if truth really is the first casualty of
war then nuance in reporting would come
a close second
that is the kind of journalism that is
coming out of ukraine the victims of
this war the news consuming public and
the story they cannot get enough of all
deserve better
ukrainian journalists have told us that
one of the more frustrating aspects of
this story has been the shortage of
ukrainian voices in the negotiations
between moscow and the west since the
invasion though some of that has changed
meenakshi ravi is here with more richard
anyone watching ukraine's media and
digital pushback over the past 10 days
will have witnessed a huge surge of
activity some of it understandably quite
chaotic but not without impact
first is the ukrainian response to
russia's digital warfare prior to the
invasion russian state-backed attacks on
ukrainian government websites were well
underway with hacks and malware
spreading into computer networks
ukraine's minister of digital
transformation mikhail fedorov then
announced the creation of a volunteer
cyber army more than 200 000 people have
signed up to a group on telegram
messenger where they're issued various
tasks
that cyber army has taken credit for
takedowns and defacements of russian
government and media sites ukrainian
media outlets have also ramped up
operations by banding together the
country's four largest media groups have
formed a body they call united news
they released a statement saying they
would join forces to provide an
uninterrupted flow of information from
across the country
one reason they had to come together was
to pool resources that are in short
supply
some outlets have asked for financial
support from news consumers around the
world
a gofundme page was set up by an
executive at the english language kiev
independent which has collected half a
million dollars in funding in less than
a week
the money is being split between
numerous outlets and is being used
specifically to help relocate key news
operations outside the war zone safer
spaces for ukrainian journalists as
russia's attacks intensify
thanks mina
back to the international side of the
ukraine story now and an aspect of the
news coverage that has left many viewers
shaking their heads
some reporters and television hosts
white ones pointing out how relatable
ukrainian refugees are with their blonde
hair their blue eyes
using words like civilized to
distinguish ukrainians from the kind of
refugees that journalists have covered
from syria for example or afghanistan
these are incidents terms that have
somehow slipped out during the live
coverage of news when stuff tends to
happen
however the framing and the terminology
expose a thing or two about double
standards in reporting depending on a
refugee's skin color or their religious
beliefs
h.a hellyer has spent a career in
academia studying europe's treatment of
ethnic minorities he joins us now
mr hellyer let's start with this there's
not a great deal of subtlety is there
and some of the bias that we've seen in
the journalism on ukraine particularly
the refugee angle
what has the coverage of this story told
you about the hierarchy of human worth
in so far as some elements of the media
are concerned so i'm glad you said some
elements in the media because i think a
lot of people have actually done the job
really well
over the past week
but we're focusing quite rightly on
not just a few rotten apples but
quite a large
phenomenon that exists in
much of the western media when it comes
to
coverage of the last week these are
christians they're white they're
they're very similar to people many
people who live in poland
and there is a hierarchy
and the hierarchy has to do with race
the hierarchy has to do with religious
affiliation we're talking about war in
the ukraine and the barbarism that is
unfolding as though it was somehow
unique it's not unique now the
unthinkable has happened to them and
this is not a developing third world
nation this is europe
we've seen
much worse than this many times
uh just over the past decade and the the
shock and horror that you see from some
elements in the western media as though
uh this was something unique and special
of course it is special because
everybody's suffering is special but
it's not unique and when we make that
argument that is unique that we haven't
seen this before it means that we're
raising and making invisible all those
people that have suffered so
tremendously in other places very often
by the way at the hands of the same
military hardware that vladimir putin is
putting to work in ukraine we're not
talking about a single journalist here
are we or even a couple this has
happened across a variety of news
outlets including this one al jazeera
what does that tell us about how widely
ingrained this kind of thinking really
is so we have two major issues here one
they're going to be people who are
frankly bluntly very openly racist and
bigoted but that's not the bigger
problem
the
structural way in which certain things
can be said
that are incredibly bigoted and racist
in and of themselves even though the
people themselves who are uttering them
might be you know very nice and very
professional and so on that's the
problem that i see right here
these are prosperous
i'm looking to use the expression these
are prosperous middle-class people these
are not obviously refugees trying to get
away from areas in the middle east i'm
not saying that all of these people are
racist i'm saying that there is a wider
issue here where we are not sufficiently
aware
of the biases that we hold and that
allows for a lot of this stuff to become
far more mainstream than we're really
comfortable talking about
given what we've heard from the media
and from some european politicians on
refugees
is it any wonder that ukrainians are
being welcomed at these borders allowed
to cross them in ways that afghans and
syrians were not
so
unfortunately i'm not surprised uh and i
say this is somebody who's been studying
uh
racial politics and
uh
and ethnic minorities in europe for 20
years and you know people have been
arguing and i've seen this you know
multiple times over the last few days
that oh well it's natural um that people
will have more of an affinity uh with
those who look like them and so on and
i'm not sure that they really recognize
entirely the uh the ramifications of
what they're saying
because most of our societies if not all
of our societies are not homogeneous
there is diversity that exists within
them right now we let alone as a result
of recent migrations of you know
refugees and so on it's quite
extraordinary that in 2022 we continue
to have to have these conversations um
and i'm very glad and grateful
that so many of our governments have
accepted ukrainian refugees that are
fleeing putin's invasion
i hope that we learn a valuable lesson
here that it's not simply ukrainians who
deserve that right and privilege
but as any human being that we have the
opportunity to help what about some of
the basic inconsistencies we're seeing
in the way that certain developments are
reported we've all seen those videos of
ukrainians making molotov cocktails
forms of resistance that are depicted in
the media
as being legitimate the styrofoam
works to make the molotov cocktail
sticky to help it stick and they're
making it according to a recipe that has
been distributed by the ukrainian
ministry of defense really quite
extraordinary unpack those videos for us
please given the way that the western
media have often depicted resistance
fighters in places like syria and
palestine so they're going to be
different ways in how these things are
going to be portrayed right these are
the only weapons she has but she says
she's ready to fight
let those russians come here she says we
are ready to greet them
when it comes to ukraine
it's russia intervening i.e not an ally
of ours into a country that we perceive
as an ally of ours there's this allied
ship
that i think is a big element in the
discussion now having said that then
there are other examples
um and you saw that in syria
where
you wouldn't necessarily be portraying
people who are fighting against bashar
al-assad in quite the same way because
the perception would be well yes we
don't like bashar al-assad but all of
these brown people they basically fight
with each other all the time and you
know it's a sunni versus shia thing and
it becomes this uh this very pseudo
complex
uh situation in order to avoid saying no
actually this is wrong and we should try
to help
um and you see in the same way and how
we describe now people who are
volunteering to go and fight in ukraine
and what's made you want to come here
they look like they need help
we're young strong fit men we can help
so why not the coverage incredibly
different than even aid workers who
wanted to go and help people in syria uh
during the early years of the war let's
dig a little deeper into syria what
should the west have learned from that
conflict given russia's involvement
there its use of misinformation in that
space and the suffering that the syrian
people experienced as a result of the
conflict so i want to take us back to
when
chemical weapons were used in syria and
the so-called red line
that then u.s president barack obama
sort of laid out and how it wasn't held
okay the line was not held it wasn't
that long after that
that you saw uh russia not only up its
game but also invade and occupy and
annex crimea
and how we got here partly at least
is one
we
systematically dehumanized all of these
populations by not considering them
worthy of solidarity but this isn't
a place with all due respect um
you know like iraq or afghanistan this
is a relatively civilized uh relatively
european i have to choose those words
carefully too uh city where you and we
see that very clearly in how we treat a
population that we actually do
want to engage in solidarity with so you
have all of these countries in the
european union but also the uk that are
now changing their visa requirements
tremendously and opening up their
borders in ways they never ever would
have done for afghans for syrians for
iraqis and so on right so that's what's
possible it's just that it's not
possible if you're not a ukrainian or
you're not perceived within this
quote-unquote white category so that's
one two
uh i think it sends a massive message
and did send a massive message to the
likes of putin
that
the west simply isn't going to
hold them accountable nor is the
international community more generally
so
these two things i think really go hand
in hand we're not simply
engaging in the systematic
dehumanization
of these populations we're also
encouraging
very aggressive
powers to engage in really negative ways
that impact on our security more
generally
and also promote
um a
far more disorderly uh world today we're
going to leave it there h.a hellyer
thanks for speaking with us here at the
listening post today thank you my
pleasure
and finally a story as big as the war in
ukraine the incessant updates the news
from across all those platforms can make
it difficult to get a wider view the
bigger picture so we thought we would
share a few articles twitter accounts
and some news outlets that we've found
helpful this past week they offer a more
nuanced view they ask some inconvenient
questions if that's what it takes
katrina vandenhoevel is the editorial
director at the american news magazine
the nation she shares threads and
articles that are worth your while like
this one from the magazine that she
oversees
another twitter account much less
prolific is that of writer anatol leaven
his article on the website responsible
statecraft was what led us to him the
site's twitter account that's
responsible statecraft is definitely
worth a follow as well
another outlet is open democracy one
article we would recommend is by
moscow-based professor greg yuden it's
getting on it was published back on
february 24th but remains relevant uden
does not have a twitter account of his
own but he is widely read inside and
outside russia you can check out this
interview that meduza did with him on
march 2nd about dissent and resistance
within russia a few other twitter
accounts that bring some nuance some
bilingual content to the mix kimberly
saint julian varnan is a historian
specializing in russia and eastern
europe she writes for the h ukraine
website and then there's elena cernenko
special correspondent at the russian
newspaper comersant finally for those
who prefer to listen to their news
rather than read it the russia guy is a
podcast run by kevin rothrock my guest
is marlene laurelle dr lararel wrote a
book last year titled is russia fascist
unraveling propaganda east and west and
it has remarkable applications to
today's crisis in ukraine
it focuses on journalism academia and
activism in the country those are some
of our recommendations for where to get
your news on this story we'll see you
next time here at the listening post